the surreal landscape of our closest
planetary neighbor scientists have taken
a close look at the surface of Mars now
for the first time they'll study the
deep interior but to get to the red
planet
NASA's insight spacecraft needs to
survive a perilous descent through the
thin atmosphere and fewer than half of
all missions have made it
it's opted for a huge parachute and then
retro rockets that should slow insight
from 13,000 miles an hour to just five
for a gentle touchdown hopefully you
know as we go through these seven
minutes of Terror kind of increasing the
likelihood of humanity to actually land
on Mars with this amazing vehicle that
is out there ready to land that will
again transform our knowledge of this
amazing planet that's right next to us
three-two-one all the instruments on
board have been tested to survive the
jolt of landing that's a little more
than we are expecting on landing and
that's the right side that we want to
test that engineers at Imperial College
in London made the missions tiny
seismometer an instrument that will
detect Mars quakes as well as the
vibrations from meteorites slamming into
the surface of the planet those tremors
should determine the structure of Mars's
interior and help scientists understand
how it and the solar system were formed
any instrument being sent to another
planet needs to be as small and light as
possible and team here at Imperial
really have cracked it these Springs are
half the width of a human hair
and yet the device is so sensitive that
when they tested it in a lab in Oxford
they were able to detect the tremors
from the local church bells if the
mission finds Mars has the remains of a
liquid core it will suggest the planet
once had a magnetic field that could
have shielded early life but then for
some reason dramatically weakened on
earth our magnetic field is very
important at protecting us from
radiation and also protecting the
atmosphere by being swept away from
SolarWinds Mars although it may have
started off in a similar place is
certainly very different much drier it's
lost nearly all of its atmosphere 99% of
it has gone there's very little water if
life did ever establish itself early on
it's been a very difficult place for it
to hang on NASA's missions have strongly
suggested Mars could have supported life
in a warmer wetter past in 2022 Rovers
will go to Mars
searching for evidence of microbes that
should finally give us the answer Thomas
More Sky News